Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is Not Allowed
To Do At The Foundation: No leading a Mobile
Task Force against the UIU
under any circumstances!
The Unusual Incidents Unit of the FBI is a
generally well-meaning, but often irritating
presence in the world of anomalous research.
It’s the annoying little brother who insists
on following you and your friends around when
you’re trying to play big boy games, for
crying out loud!
But that doesn’t mean that it’s acceptable
to lead a Mobile Task Force against them.
With Bright’s newly formed task force, he
approached a UIU building and proceeded to
order a series of “ding dong ditches,”
wherein task force members would ring the
doorbell and then run away laughing before
anyone could catch them.
They also covered the exterior of the building
in eggs, toilet paper, and a substance later
revealed to be a lightly radioactive form
of silly string.
Though no real damage was done, this behavior
was described by the O5 Council as “just
kind of mean?”
Dr. Bright has been prohibited from leading
any more Task Forces in the future.